Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
El arte de las películas existe
desde hace más de cien años.
La forma de hacer películas
no ha cambiado mucho
desde una perspectiva dimensional.
Poner una cámara y apretar grabar,
no ha cambiado.
El cine sigue siendo
una experiencia frontal,
y todavía se percibe como tal.
La experiencia de ver películas
sigue igual desde su creación.
Uno se para enfrente de una pantalla
y mira la imagen presentada.
De hecho, no hay nada malo en eso.
Me encanta ir al cine,
ver películas en TV;
la experiencia de ver historias
en movimiento
puede ser tan poderosa que hasta
nos impulsa emocionalmente.
La pregunta que nos hacemos
es cómo las historias en movimiento
pueden existir más allá
de la pantalla plana.
Si miramos a los medios del futuro
hay una oportunidad de crear contenido
que se adapte a las nuevas plataformas.
Cuando filmamos una película,
tradicionalmente, imaginamos
una escena dentro de un enmarque,
creando profundidad
con primer plano, medio y fondo,
mientras la cámara se mueve.
Obviamente, con los nuevos
tipos de dispositivos
como gafas de realidad virtual
o realidad aumentada
o plataformas inteligentes nuevas
que nos permiten navegación en 3D
hay una oportunidad de crear
contenido mucho más inmersivo.
Ya de una manera que
nos podríamos mover adentro
y tratar de ver la experiencia
desde una nueva perspectiva.
No estoy hablando de videojuegos
o de personajes creados con computadora,
aunque se vean súper reales.
Estoy hablando de actuación real.
Actuación de carne y hueso.
Actuación artística.
Para hacer una cosa así
tendríamos que empezar a redefinir
o pensar nuevas tecnologías y metodologías
para permitir estas nuevas experiencias.
Ya conocemos la filmación en 360 grados,
poniendo una cámara en el centro
que nos permite crear una imagen
en 360 grados, envolvente,
y nos lleva un paso más adelante ya
de una interacción.
Pero todavía sigue siendo
una experiencia frontal.
Para empezar a mirar cómo
podríamos meternos en la escena
tendríamos que capturar la luz
desde todos los ángulos,
poniendo cámaras y sensores
para poder capturar toda la luz,
desde todas las perspectivas.
Estas soluciones nos permiten
recrear al sujeto en tres dimensiones.
Vendría a ser como una fotografía en 3D.
Esto nos permite no nada más
grabar la imagen en un plano
sino capturarla como un volumen.
Esto es lo que llamamos
video volumétrico.
Es el proceso de capturar la luz
y guardarla dentro de un voxel.
Pero ¿qué es un voxel?
Un voxel es como un pixel
en tres dimensiones.
En vez de ser un cuadrado plano
con la información de luz,
es como un cubo en el espacio,
con posición X, Y y Z,
guardando toda la información de
luz desde todas las perspectivas.
Esta metodología nos permite
generar un volumen de luz
visible desde todos lados.
Y con esto podemos empezar a pensar
y abrir las oportunidades
de nuevo contenido.
Obviamente, para capturar
y crear cine y escenas e historias
con este tipo de solución
tendríamos que crear un espacio
suficientemente grande como para
alojar escenas y montajes enteros,
y suficientemente poderoso como
para instalar cientos de cámaras
y procesar esa cantidad
inmensa de información.
Parece una idea un poco loca,
pero es exactamente lo que hicimos.
En los últimos tres años hemos estado
construyendo el estudio del futuro.
Instalamos cientos de cámaras.
Y construimos un domo gigantesco
que nos permite crear
exactamente lo que queríamos.
Lo llamamos Intel Studios.
Es la cámara volumétrica
más grande del mundo,
para desarrollar, investigar y definir
nuevas metodologías
para contenido interactivo.
Pero ¿qué quiere decir
contenido interactivo?
¿Qué quiere decir meternos en la escena?
Para probar estas nuevas
hipótesis e ideas
decidimos, para la primera vez
que usamos el estudio,
elegir una escena clásica.
Elegimos una escena del lejano Oeste.
Trajimos escenarios, llenamos el estudio
de tierra, actores, cuatro caballos,
para recrear una escena entera
pero esta vez capturada
desde todos los ángulos.
Los actores, para trabajar en estos
nuevos medios, enfrentaron un desafío.
Tenían que actuar de manera impecable
que sea vista desde todos los ángulos.
Ya no hay más una posición frontal
que uno nada más la refiere.
Sino que tienen que pensar
en todas las perspectivas.
Muy parecido al teatro.
Veamos ahora un poco
el primer resultado que salió.
Esto que ven nos abrió los ojos
a las oportunidades que podemos tener
con estas nuevas tecnologías y medios.
El resultado fue un escaneo total
y entero de toda la escena.
Y nos permitió movernos adentro de
una manera libre que no podíamos antes.
Con esta nueva solución podemos ver
no solo la imagen o la luz
emitida en una pantalla
sino meternos en la luz
y navegar adentro del volumen,
percibiéndolo desde nuevos ángulos.
Veamos ahora una de las tomas que
renderizamos usando esta tecnología.
Lo que verán está hecho totalmente
con una cámara virtual
que se mueve en el espacio.
(Video volumétrico)
(Fin del video volumétrico)
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Como pueden ver, logramos tener
con esta solución un control total
del espacio y del movimiento,
permitiendo nuevos ángulos y libertad
para creación de contenido.
Pero ¿qué más podemos hacer
con esta libertad?
¿Podemos poner una cámara virtual
en los ojos de los actores,
desde los puntos de vista?
¿Y si en vez del actor
elegimos al caballo?
Veamos la misma escena,
no hubo una nueva toma,
pero esta vez desde el caballo.
(Video volumétrico)
(Fin del video volumétrico)
(Aplausos)
El caballo no fue dañado y ninguna
cámara fue puesta en su cabeza.
Realmente, esto libera las posibilidades
de navegar dentro de la escena.
Esto es perfecto para cineastas
o creadores de contenido
ya que les da las herramientas para
crear estas nuevas visualizaciones.
Pero ¿qué pasa con la audiencia?
Podemos investigar cómo
la audiencia puede meterse.
Para eso nos asociamos
con Paramount Pictures.
Investigamos cómo serían las experiencias
y las historias en movimiento,
interactivas,
en unas películas de Hollywood.
Nos juntamos con el director
Randal Kleiser
y recreamos la película
Grease de 1978.
Trayendo 20 bailarines al escenario
recreamos la canción
"You're the one that I want"
en una toma totalmente nueva.
Lo que ven acá, realmente permitió
a los directores, y a nosotros,
romper las barreras de pensar en 2D.
Y empezar a pensar de manera
totalmente nueva
y hacer surgir nuevas herramientas
para el contenido y la creación
de nuevas historias.
Pero ¿por qué verlo de manera plana?
Vamos a invitarlos al escenario.
No de verdad, los traeremos
en realidad aumentada.
Usaré esta tableta,
estoy mapeando el escenario,
registrando la información en 3D.
(Aplausos)
Vamos a ver qué dicen.
(Video RA)
(Palmas)
(Fin del video RA)
(Aplausos)
Gracias a los bailarines aumentados.
Como pueden ver,
el contenido se puede experimentar
como una película tradicional
o como una experiencia inmersiva.
Todo depende de cómo
y con qué lo estamos viendo.
No estamos tratando de cambiar los modos
tradicionales de crear contenido,
sino potenciarlos.
Estamos en un momento único
en la historia del cine,
abriendo y entendiendo nuevas maneras
de crear contenido inmersivo.
El viaje acaba de empezar.
Los invito a todos a unirse.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)